we're concentrating on knife crime this
is after a fourth fatal stabbing in the
space of just six days and there are now
calls for the prime minister to put
10,000 police officers back on to the
streets senior Labour politicians
including the London mayor said he can
have written this in a joint letter to
to reason may well we can get more now
on the knife crime crisis we can speak
to the Mayor of London Sadiq Khan who is
in our Westminster Studio forest this
morning good morning to Sadiq Khan and
just looking at the statistics I mean
they are frightening for people up and
down the country but focusing in on
London in particular there have been 21
fatalities relating to knife crime since
the start of this year and people this
morning want to know what you're doing
about it and it's distressing five of
those mother have been teenagers and
I've met many breed families and
grieving siblings as well a number of
things we do not with some of the
challenges we have City Hall have funded
a violent crime task force 300 targeting
high knife crime areas over the course
of the first eight months they've made
more than 3,000 arrests leading to
charges and taken more than a thousand
knives offensive weapons and guns off
our streets additionally we have
invested in young people giving them
preventative things to do forty five
million pounds in a young Londoners fund
but the point I make is this the causes
of the increase in violent crime are
extremely complex deep-seated problems
I'm not excusing criminality poverty
social alienation inequalities mental
health issues issues around exclusions
made far worse by the massive cuts we've
had a police officer numbers but also
massive cuts in youth services and
preventative services as well that's why
we're lobbying the prime minister to
step in and take a lead in this issue
you're also lobbying the Prime Minister
on school exclusions today that's
something that you're focusing on this
morning because you've mentioned a wide
range of issues here I just want to know
why you're focusing on school exclusions
they've increased by 56% in the last
three years but where's the evidence
that this is linked to the rise in knife
crime I'll remove a question so we're
not saying nobody's saying that
exclusions is the sole reason why
there's been a massive increase in
violent crime across the country not the
sole reason but where is the where
the link well a few things firstly in in
little Wells the education system is
different to in scholars of
fragmentation you have maintained
schools academies and free schools and
many council leaders we speak to have
got no idea what's happening in the
various schools in their patch in
Scotland where the schools are
maintained councils are more in control
and have more of a say and give more
support to the schools when children
become disruptive or show patterns that
can eventually lead to them being
excluded so the point we're making is if
you look at Glasgow in Scotland for
example in 2017 only one child was
excluded because there the resources and
support to take measures before a child
got to be excluded in England Wales in
2017 more than 7,000 children were
excluded an increase from four thousand
three years before so excluded how many
of them have gone on to commit knife
crime I'm just trying to find a link
we're talking about knife crime crisis
I'm just trying to find out what the
actual link is between school exclusions
and knife crime because it does seem
like an odd thing to be focusing on when
you talk about a plethora of issues one
of them being you know tougher
sentencing the other being stop and
search why are you focusing on school
exclusions one of you should have
focusing on the hm might be the prison's
Inspectorate recently said that when
they visited secured training centres
young offenders institutions and nine
have ten people in custody were excluded
children we know when you speak to a
dull offenders many of them when they
were younger were exclude often by the
way for very good reasons if you're a
head teacher even understand why you
want to make sure that education of the
vast majority of children is not made
worse by a disruptive child or a violent
child but also the Children's
Commissioner and Ofsted of expressed
concern about this issue of off rolling
that's where a head teacher doesn't
exclude a child but takes them off the
role in consultation with the parent or
of the vulnerable carer and parent and
the point we're making amongst the
various of a variety of other points is
these are vulnerable children who
without support can go on to get
involved in criminal gangs or get
involved in criminality I'm not by any
way saying that every child is you
exclude returning to a criminal but
there is a link and we think we think
the government the Prime Minister needs
to take ownership of this issue okay Oh
well you think it's one of the causes
them there maybe leading to this spike
in knife crime let's talk about the
effect of which we are seeing on the
streets last night somebody died in East
London and ready stand on stop and
search because a lot of people are
riding this wave of support for it like
the Prime Minister you've never been a
huge fan of this and police though are
saying they think it's a vital tactic do
you support their efforts to make stop
and search more widely use once again it
is a violent act a vital attack I've
seen it myself the difference that can
made when used properly in London I
can't speak for us the country there's
been a game-changer which is that I've
made sure that we've rolled out the
biggest body warm videos of any police
force in the world every police officer
in London has a body warm video why is
that important it gives us a police
officer confidence to use this really
important tool knowing the interactions
going to be recorded so a vexatious
complaint one we made against the police
officer but it also gives Londoners
confidence knowing the instructions
being recorded I've always seen in
London over the recent past is an
increase in the use of stop and search
but the number of complaints is stating
actually gone down and I think body-worn
videos has been the ball game changer
for us in London yeah it's interesting
isn't it because you're now saying you
think it's a vital tool when you were
campaigning to become mayor of London
you said you do everything in your power
to bring stop and search down and when
you campaign to be mayor you made
violent crime in London at the heart of
your manifesto including knife crime
you're elected three years ago on that
manifesto and three years in on your
watch knife crime in the capital as it
is at its highest level on record you're
getting a lot of criticism for this
looking at that is it justified have you
lost control on this issue well you've
raised four points in one question I
never deal with each one out of time
first in relation to my campaign I was
quite clear that the industrial
indiscriminate use of stop and search is
wrong in London the big game changes
being the body warrant video which gives
accountability but also it's targeted
and intelligence led in the first eight
months of the City Hall funding violent
crime task force because of stop and
search is one of the reasons we've heard
more than 3,000 arrests leading to
charges but also more than a thousand
knives offensive weapons and guns taken
off as troops that would be used against
that's the first point the second point
is in London just London alone over the
last eight years I've met police service
has lost more than 800 million pounds
from central government's consequence of
cuts but slit toss have in more than
3,000 fewer police officers thousands of
fewer community officers and thousands
of for your police staff on top of that
dozens of you centres closing down
hundreds of you are visiting their jobs
thousands of young Londoners with a have
a new youth centre to go to what don't
from City Hall is used in council tax
increases I've raised at three years in
a row the previous mayor didn't raise it
but also use monies from business race
to invest in policing but also to invest
in youth services and young people the
investment we're giving doesn't fill the
massive hole left by central government
funding this much when the whole central
government and I understand that the
cuts they're well documented they are
well documented but just in terms of
your personal responsibility if he
didn't believe he could effect change
when you campaign to become mayor of
London why put it at the heart of your
manifesto if you're gonna hold your
hands up now and go look at central
government we haven't got enough funding
what can you be doing as mayor of London
what personal responsibilities are you
taking for this well I was explaining
some of the things that we're doing the
steagle fund the violent crime I know
but while you're explaining what's being
done and these wheels are in motion
knife crime is going up
people are dying too people in London in
the last few days well also somebody
unfortunately Oxford last night somebody
in my store on Friday yes maybe your
mayor of London so I want to talk about
what's happening in London and what
personal responsibility you're taking
and what powers you have as mayor of
London away from government to do
something well 80% of the budget for the
Met Police Service 80 percent comes from
central government roughly speaking 20%
comes from City Hall we've increased as
much as I'm allowed to do under the law
secondly we've invested 45 million
pounds in a young Londoners fund at the
moment there are 60,000 young London as
a receiving support they weren't before
I became mayor